hello there friends how are you doing so
um this is going to be more informal
than my usual videos because it's really
just an announcement video Uh
something's pretty uh pretty special
happened uh a few weeks ago which is
that uh I topped 100,000 subscribers
here on YouTube which is really awesome
and something that I have been looking
forward to now for quite some time um
and i' I've been trying to find a way to
commemorate it U I'm going to have a get
together with some friends uh to you
know kind of Mark this auspicious
occasion but I also wanted to find a way
to commemorate it with all of you
watching out there and to thank you for
uh tuning in and making this possible in
the first place and I think what I've
settled on is I'm going to do a Q&A that
is um so this video exists to announce
that Q&A and to tell you how to
participate in it namely um leave a
comment on this video right here leave
me your questions and in a couple weeks
I will come back and do a video where I
answer as many of those questions as
possible um I'm excited for it uh my my
silver play button just came in the mail
a few days ago I haven't had a chance to
open it yet but I will uh I I will
definitely be uh showing you all that
silver play button in the uh Q&A video I
can't wait to do that um so yeah once
again uh leave me a comment ask me your
questions any topic that you like
whether you want to know about uh
something about my career something
about me as a person um some random
question you have that you like to ask
to strangers I don't know but um I'm I'm
opening up the floor to all of you so um
please be kind and uh leave those
questions down in the comments section
uh thank you and uh before we head out
of course um I should do all of the
normal things uh like thanking the
friends of the channel uh big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys uh juggling calling pyate ter light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible and of course you can learn
more about all of these amazing
companies uh at the links that I have
down in the description and seriously
thanks to each and every one of you for
supporting me and helping me get to this
point and also big thanks to the non-
buus friend of the channel That is Becca
Becken and to everybody who says I keep
pronouncing that more violently you
should learn how to pronounce Finnish um
but Pekka thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and of course um all the videos
on this channel would not be possible
without my amazing patreon supporters
and in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who uh are
listed on screen right now thank you you
all are freaking
awesome uh and if y'all out there
watching want to uh want to want to get
on this uh want to get on this train and
uh support this work that I'm doing
because uh apparently it uh it is work
that has had quite an impact um you can
do that by signing up for my patreon
over at patreon.com drexfactor poy
there's some awesome rewards that are
available over there um but the biggest
thing is you'll be helping me continue
to make videos like this one and keep on
building awareness and support for Po
and flow Arts all over the world so
check that out please and thank you um
yeah so now I'm going to go um thanks
for everything all of you out there and
I can't wait to see what questions you
ask reminder leave them down in the
comment section uh any question that
comes to mind and uh I will do my best
to answer
them that's really exciting um seriously
thank you all out there thank you so
much